please be good please be good please be
good please because a big guy Ralph
breaks the internet it's really funny
that intro I did that for a fact but
everyone seen the movie sorry know what
I think we make Internet magic we tell
truth through lies so Ralph breaks the
Internet is wreck-it Ralph - which I'm
probably gonna call this record Ralph -
in the course of this reveal just being
a realist
and Ralph breaks the Internet Ralph and
his friend vanellope they've been
friends for a few years in vanilla peas
game breaks is a vintage game where do
you get a part for something like that -
land of peace and prosperity the
internet love that was true anyway
prosperity sure peace only here cuz this
is a place of fun welcome to my sandbox
so they have to go into the internet now
bring on the new adventure we're now the
sequel to wreck-it Ralph a movie that's
awesome I'm not gonna lie to you the
first trailer for this movie that came
out I was like alright so wreck-it Ralph
one of the really cool things about it
was all the video game references in
this one they just go on the internet
like the emoji movie I've seen that full
transparency and if you saw the second
trailer I didn't care the scenarios I
saw before me were care enough to be
really nervous about this movie and then
be let down by it or just don't care
enough to sneak out the second trailer I
did that second one but holy crap I
really dug this movie it's a lesson to
me don't watch the trailers makes the
movie better the Ralph and vanellope
friendship it's still here it still
works it's actually very front and
center in this story other than that
very obvious thing what I liked about
this movie which is I really dug the
humor this movie has a brilliant way of
illustrating in Internet ISM of some
sort it was not myself right there I
don't want to spoil the jokes in this
movie because I didn't know what they
were gonna be and so that was gonna have
the funds like oh my gosh they're
referencing this so I'm not gonna tell
you specifics I'm just saying it was
really enjoyable seeing a concept of the
Internet shown in a three dimensional
space it Illustrated how you would see
it if you were walking down the street
and that's how that interaction went
down I love that and that's very
prominent for a lot of this movie I
thought this movie is just gonna be
Disney vomiting their properties into
here I mean it happens of course you saw
that in the first trailer but that
Disneyland or whatever it was like I
guess it's not Disneyland of
Disneyland's like a place that we have
but whatever they call it it's the
Disney World in here and you see a lot
of Disney Princesses Disney property
it's like Star Wars and I was really
nervous for this movie like I said the
video game reference is I love that like
scene and bison in a Disney
it's really surprising to me I didn't
think I would ever see that in the
course of my entire life ever the
stormtroopers yeah I imagine but the way
this movie delivers it they actually
have fun with it but they don't linger
and the online Disney reference space
for too long it's fun to see it
reference it jabbing it and then get out
that's a smart way to play it that's how
they played it in his movie it's a big
Internet out there you have enough
things to reference you don't have to
stick around in your own indulgent pool
video game references are still in here
especially at the very beginning you do
have a few there and the concept that
they are from video games and there are
video games online is in this movie I
don't want to act like video game
references or not this movie does
recognise where it comes from and while
when I got out of wreck-it Ralph I
wanted to see more of that in a record
Ralph - I'm not disappointed with where
they took record Ralph - or Ralph breaks
the internet something you might
remember some of you might have heard
whispers among your parents talking
about movies but I'm long pass before
Disney was like the property Hydra you
cut one head off two more heads grow in
its place of two more properties each
head of the hydras and other
entertainment property of some sort well
for all that nonsense Disney were the
ones that they were the tip of the spear
they were the ones delivering some
really great storytelling in the form of
animation
I really felt this movie took it back to
that time I mean yeah product placement
it's in here but I just didn't care
because I cared more about the movie
every movie has product placement a
movie about the Internet's gonna have
more tricky is to make the audience not
care because they're more invested in
something else there's like an
investment threshold there if the
audience doesn't care about the movie
they're gonna notice the product
placement they're gonna see it as a
negative if they're invested in the
movie the product placements just kind
of a byproduct and make a movie what do
you think about this movie every time I
felt like it was dipping or it was gonna
dip like example you see where something
happens to Ralph he sees something and
he's kind of at a low and instead of
staying with that they go over to
vanellope
and initially I was like you should have
stayed with Ralph for a little longer
but the scene with Penelope was so good
that by the end of her scene I was like
I don't know how I would have done a
different look that was just damn
entertaining and like any good movie or
any good animation I know as being good
myself is that well it's entertaining
you with the laughs well it's
entertaining you with the adventure it
hit she was something real it teaches
you a lesson and by the end of this
movie yes it hits you with the real it
gives you that deeper message of growth
for life that you're used to seeing in
the good Disney Animation Adventure at
one point in this movie I was like
that's really profound I just I don't
know let you say yourself and it was at
that moment I was like this is really
back to before Disney was the corporate
monster there is a point in the last act
like the first two acts go where it
looks like the movies wrapping up and
then hey there's this other thing and if
a movie does that and doesn't pull it
off it feels a bit sloppier if a movie
does do it and does pull it off it's the
end two-face segment in The Dark Knight
kind of felt like that but it's still
awesome in the Dark Knight and it's
awesome in here because in the end Ralph
breaks the internet really spoke to me
whether it's jabbing at the radicular
stuff I find absurd online or addressing
a very relevant message about the
Internet and maybe a business model of
YouTube possibly I really dug this one
and by the end it really hit me in the
center it hit me deep it's a movie that
pays respect to its characters and knows
that the characters are us it's like
there's something in them that we see in
us - how you gonna reach us with that I
will say Ralph breaks the internet is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray because it is awesome tacular I
think I use that fake out in another
review can't think of the movie for
anything after I got another movie I
watched a couple of reviews I haven't
seen all the reviews for Ralph breaks
the internet but the couple that I did
seek out I was like okay so I like this
movie like a lot more than you do don't
know that means I don't know what it
says about me I don't know but it is
what it is I love this movie alright so
Ralph breaks the Internet have you seen
it what did you think about it but Aria
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]